Okay, everybody. Welcome back. This is a little
mini lesson, we are going to do, talking about how
to use templates. And we are going to spend a
lot of time today in our editor and browser,
basically working together to build a few templates in
a simple web application. So let's start with what
a basic web application looks like. Here we have
a, a basic little web application. This is effectively
the Hotel World homework that you did from lesson,
from the first lesson. And you know as you can
see it doesn't really do much. It's got one
handler on slash called main page. Which is here. And
all it does is it prints the string hello,
Udacity. I've made my main page handler inherit from a
class called Handler, which I defined up here. And
this just adds one method called Write. And all write
is, it just let's me print a string without
having to type self response.out.write, I can just type
self .write. And we'll be adding a few more
helper functions, to this handler, as we go. So we've
got this basic file here, we've got this basic
app.yamal, you know, nothing, nothing crazy here, this is,
this should all be familiar to you by now.
let's go ahead, and make sure this works. We go
to our terminal. I'm in the template lesson directory,
where these files are. As you can see, ,we'll run
the app server, like so I, I prefer to run
the app server from the terminal so I can just
see what's going on, and can kill it easily,
it's telling me we're running at local host 8080, so
let's go ahead and check that out in browser. We'll
go to local host 8080. We'll load this page, and
we see our text that I typed hello, Udacity!
Let's just make sure everything is working as expected.
I'm just going to change this string, adding a
few exclamation marks. I'll save this file and the go
back to our browser and reload, and just make
sure that everything is working end to end. Okay.
Here I am in the browser. I reload. My
extra exclamation marks appeared. So we are all good there.
Now in this slide, I'm going to ask you lots
of questions like, what happens when you do x or
y or whatever. So try to follow along with
me as we go. that'll, that'll kind of keep things going
smoothly. Now you're remember if from the end of
your homework from lesson two um,where we made a basic form, if you want to make
a basic form we can just return html directly from our handler here. So
I'm going to add a quick string that represents an HTML form.
I'm going to start with a triple quota string. This is basically
the python syntax for a multi line string. Anything I type
between these two triple quotes will just be a part of a
string, including other quotes and such. So, it just makes it
typing html a little easier. Okay? So, a form tag, remember
that just starts a form. A little h2 tag, that will
just add a little title. An input box, type text and we'll
give it the name food. And the button to
add this food. Now it looks like we're building
some sort of food or shopping sort of thing
and indeed we are, we'll kind of build there as we
go. But for right now its going to start with
this basic form. App returns this html and the fact,
I am going to rename this form html, so it's
little bit easier to see down here. So, let's replace
this text with form HTML and we will give
this a [UNKNOWN] in the browser. Reload the page. And
I see a basic form. Now, recall that since
we didn't set a method on that form, the default
method is going to be GET. Which means when I
submit this form, it'll just add that parameter to the
URL. And let's go ahead and see that work. Okay,
so I, typed in a food in the text box.
And when I hit enter, the page reloaded with
the food I just entered in the URL. Our first
quiz is going to be. When I type in a
new food. In this text box and hit add. What
happens? When I submit a new food in the
text box, what happens? Choose the correct answer. The food
parameter in the URL updates to match our new food.
Do we see a second food parameter in the URL,
so it'll have both steak and eggs in
the URL. Or, does the browser report an error?